it's that time of the year CPAs and
accountants will sit with their clients
entrepreneurs and tell them hey mr. mrs.
entrepreneur you should consider giving
some money back to charity because it
benefits you when it comes down to taxes
so as much as you do want to give back
to charity because it benefits your tax
wise depending on the country you're
living today I want to talk to you about
why you should consider giving back to
the community as an entrepreneur and how
to give back to the community so if
you're wondering where I'm at right now
in the background I'm at Bakersfield
therefore with Mary o in the world it is
truly one of the smallest airports
Bakersfield great city my body back here
in a paper plane kid and we had to shoot
a video because tomorrow is a video
that's due so let me get right into it
listen there's two ways to give back to
the community one is money when is your
time so why should you consider giving
back to the community there's really
five points and our very simple points
why you should consider giving back to
the community the most important one in
my opinion is law of reciprocity let me
tell you what's a law of reciprocity I
truly believe the more I give the more I
get in return not an expectation I just
feel good things happen to me the more I
give I'm a big believer brought a law of
reciprocity I don't know how many get
this thing in return maybe one day
someone's gonna do something for my son
my daughter my family somebody close to
me that is gonna benefit me but I
believe in the law of reciprocity the
second benefit that every time I
participate in any kind of way of giving
back to the community is I've built so
many new relationships it's very weird
we were just on Hawaii doing something
with foresters and we were building the
school and we were painting some walls
and I was given the color a pink
painting this chair pink it was
hilarious and we made such incredible
relationships with people that we still
communicate with online but it doesn't
matter what it is every single time I've
given back to any kind of charity
there's always been an opportunity to
build new relationships you have the
part when you give back to charity is
you'll learn a new skill set you'll
learn something new
when you're giving back there's
something that you're learning whether
that charity whatever they stand for
you're learning something about the
charity you're learning something that
you can benefit yourself maybe they're
telling you hey what we do is we help
families test for this so now you
learned about that new skill set fourth
one I would tell you would be your heart
like your heart gets I don't not explain
this to you it kind of your heart goes
in the mode of giving back so it almost
becomes gentler and it gets in the mood
of understanding everybody else's
position in a different way when you do
give back and you're around other people
that want to give back so it influences
you if you're somebody that's extremely
strong and rigid and military background
charity will do very very very good
things to you and fifth point simple
self esteem you feel like you're making
a difference
keeps you grounded you feel like the
world needs you you feel like you are
needed in a way you realize how
incredible of a life you have as an
entrepreneur we do give back so you know
those five things alone outside of the
tax benefit I highly recommend why you
ought to consider giving back now the
question then becomes a lot of people
ask me Pat how do I give back what do I
do I got how many points do I have here
Mari I think I wrote eleven points here
on how to give back and you can pick and
choose on how to do them so the first
one we were having a conversation
earlier today at the stress from what
was a restaurants named Paris something
to me pedo pedo and I hate some
plantains it was amazing plantains was
amazing at this place and their ceviche
was a pescado ceviche was like ceviche
it was a nice shrimp it was was amazing
with our friends del Toro Alejandro and
the rest of the people BFG conky said as
we had a great time there but one of the
guys asked me question Alejandro asked
me a question and he said hey what do
you do when your family starts asking
you for all this money and they want to
borrow money and all this other stuff I
said I don't believe in lending money to
people especially friends and family
because I believe it's a fastest way to
create an enemy says what do you mean by
that
I said because if you
and money and you say yes they love you
but it's guaranteed that they're most
likely going to come back and later on
ask for what more money and at some
point you have to say what no so if you
give money from yourself to somebody
else your family's not gonna be happy
they give money to somebody else
possibly if they're lending money and
then to if you do loan money to friends
and family you will typically see them
avoiding your next family gatherings and
you feel uncomfortable cuz you look like
you're bill collector and they kind of
don't like you it's just not a fun game
to lend money so I like to give money
let me explain what I mean by that so
somebody asked me a question and they
say Pat can you lend me $5,000 I'll
generally say no I won't lend you $5,000
but I'll give you $300 you don't ever
have to give it back so they don't like
me they don't hate me
it's a very neutral position but I gave
some money back and I'm good to go why
because I'm not in the game I don't
think the biggest benefit is just money
being given away although money you need
to give away because some organizations
need money to do their work that they do
this is why my number one point on how
to give back it's for teaching of
skillset teach a new skill set go help
somebody and give back to your community
by teaching something you're very very
good at teach somebody else how to do it
what could that be I don't know how to
get ready for a job interview go and
teach people how to be prepared for a
job interview go and sit down and sit
down with 50 people and tell them I'm
gonna interview you and you're gonna
know exactly what types of questions
we're gonna ask and I'm gonna prepare
you on how to ask those questions great
give back by teaching people how to put
a resume together give back by sitting
down and teaching somebody how to sell
something give back by teaching some
kind of a new skill set that you have
social media whatever it is but give
back to your community by teaching
something you know could be music could
be piano could be guitar it doesn't
matter
free lessons for soccer for it doesn't
matter somehow someway give back and
teach a new skill set because that'll
last that last I think skill set lasts
and it generates and gives them freedom
so number one is skillset number two is
volunteer your time at a hospital or
school it's very easy thing to do
anytime you go to school and you're
giving back whether it's big brother or
you know somebody that's needs some kind
of help I've done many many things with
school where I was hired to going not
hired I didn't even ask for the money
was a LAUSD I went and spoke to the you
know troubled kids where they had the
anklets and they were imprisoned at the
time where they were thirteen-year-old
girls that were pregnant or drug dealers
and they put me through a six-month
program that I would come down every
other week and I would take these kids
and we would talk about the biggest
thing they struggle with and they would
tell me how much they struggle with
pornography or pressure of having sex or
drugs or joining gangs or fights or
arguments with parents or what do I do
when my mom and dad my mom's on drugs my
dad's on drugs my parents aren't there
I'm living on the streets I'm this I'm
that what all this stuff and it was one
way for them to know that somebody out
there is X at least caring about them
the reason why that's very important
because when I was 13 years old and my
parents got a divorce and I was a
troubled kid I was recruited by
basketball league in Echo Park called
new century Basketball Association and
they got to get all the troubled kids
and gangsters and all this other stuff
and we play basketball together so that
made a very big impact in my life to
know man aldermen named Vladimir not
older man at that time I was 20 years
older than me Vladimir was like an older
brother to me and he gave me direction
and hope to know that somebody believes
in me that played a very big role in my
life so you don't even know who's in
who's gonna be making an impact in
Europe and who you're gonna be making an
impact in their lives but one of the
simplest ways is hospitals and schools
the other one is organize a food drive
Marya I don't know how many times we've
done this but I remember for many many
years when we were in LA every Christmas
morning at 5:30 in the morning we'd go
to school so Union rescue mission
downtown la downtown LA at 5:30 in the
morning and we would go and give away
toothpaste toothbrush pillows towels and
then we'd go to McDonald's and buy a
hundred hundred fifty McMuffins and come
back and give food and blankets and you
know another group that would go there
with sing carols - damn it was it was
just fascinating food drive because
sometimes you'd be amazed how many
people just need a simple meal
went went if eclis when people come to
me and they tell me when somebody is
begging on the streets and they ask me
for money I always offer food I saw by
your meal and if they say now I just
want money I don't give him money
because then I know what's taking place
with the money but I said why do you
need money
all because of food ok let me go by for
you ha you know what then I know exactly
where they ran but if they want me to
buy my food no problem was in Chicago
one night it was 1 o'clock in the
morning I landed I'm so hungry I go to
this only pub that was open late at
night and they were offering steak in
this one homeless man outside is like
Emma can you give me 20 bucks I'm like
man you're a big thinker if you ask him
for 20 bucks and he says hey can you
give me 20 bucks I know but I'll buy
your meal he said no problem man I'm so
hungry so what do you want to have he
says any I think I Melissa have dinner
together I take him in the restaurant
the owner says no no no he's not welcome
your bigs outside all the time I said
look I'm paying he says but he can't
come and said I said no problem
I said what do you want to order give
him a menu he gives him a menu and I
said what do you want he says I want a
prime rib I said what else do you want
he ordered his food so they bring my
food I could eat inside then I let him
eat in inside
I had him serve his primer about side to
him and the drinks outside to him he ate
his meal it was happy I ate I left
purpose was served and I didn't give him
money but I'd be giving food there's
many ways you can give back that's gonna
help people out smallest occasion so you
have no idea how much that means to that
person that person's got a stomach full
of food that night to go to sleep and
they're good to go fourth way coach kids
my brother-in-law CEO Mac why call him a
saint I've never met a man like him he
he is so gentle as a man with kids that
every parent that he was coaching his
son with his son Shawn is like a phenom
you know soccer player the guy's an
absolute beast of a left kicks with his
left foot but did you know that he's
insane I mean when he plays the team
knows they're gonna win and so he was
asked by parents after a great job he
did last season they want him to coach
again so he when I'm coached again and
so one of the ways you can coach is if
you have a good tolerance for kids and
you played high school football or
baseball or basketball or soccer and you
know the basic
this tactics because you were part of it
give back if you've done some organized
sports us one do as you can do it number
five help raise money for certain
charity or foundation just recently
we've been teamed up with Susan G Komen
now for I don't know how many years and
Jennifer my wife is very instrumental on
the way she's working with Susan G Komen
and many of the ladies so this time we
had many many events across the country
I don't know how many events this was
like 10 so all over the country we did
events and money was raised I mean it
could have been as small as $250 to
being raised as much as eleven twelve
thousand dollars and then that money
goes to Susan G Komen why while for them
it could be you know 68% of money is
used for research and they're gonna find
out ways for breast cancer my
grandmother had breast cancer and both
of them have to be you know and it's a
very emotional difficult thing a woman
goes through and a lot of times you can
do a simple testing that you know
they're educating women on how to test
for that I just think it's very
important so find out what research
means a lot to you go support that
charity there's many of them out there
that you can participate in go online
look them up and find something that
means a lot to you and if you're part of
a company that supports a certain
charity and support them as well but on
top of that be able to support other
charities that mean a lot to you support
those causes as well 6 is elderly homes
you know sometimes elderly homes they
just want somebody to talk to believe it
or not when you go to elderly homes if I
can tell you the one question to ask
when you do go to elderly homes is
here's my favorite question to ask what
invention was completely crazy when it
happened in your lifetime and you will
you will have some of the most random
conversations when somebody says I
remember when they said this one machine
was coming out that we were gonna watch
shows on it and it was television how
was it our first person in the city that
had it it was crazy so when you go there
ask them also ways that you can learn
from them hey I'm a Great Depression
baby how was it you know I'm a great
this how what you know it doesn't matter
somebody could be 95 years old and they
you know 90 years old and they're still
able to talk and you just sitting there
talking and there's a lot that you can
give back
to them so that's air elderly next one
is giving money it's very simple give
money away to different types of things
and one is I talked about seed research
the other one is just giving money away
to certain things that need help with it
doesn't matter what it is it could be a
local community that they're building a
park for kids great go contribute for
that then it's building up local
businesses this is a simple one find out
what local business is a new local
business a new business that got started
and they're just kind of trying to get
it going help promote their business
help get the word of mouth out there to
help them out it doesn't matter what it
is I'm always amazed by sometimes when
people don't want to support new
business owners help that person go out
there it help them if they got something
good you like go tell the world about it
you know you go to a nice restaurant
like even right now when you're watching
this commit today to posting one small
business in your area that just got
started that you like the most it could
be a coffee shop it could be a
restaurant it could be a you know gym
you go to that's not the traditional big
gym it could be anything that you go to
post a link on your Facebook page and
say why you like it
very simple post it on Twitter and say
why you like it simple as that it's
simple as that on what you need to do
one link tag it to them they'll be
grateful you're doing that and two other
people will look at you and say man he
or she endorses other small business and
sports other businesses I like his
approach I'm wondering what he or she
does that's you then we have going big
I'm a big fan of going big I think you
got a go make tens if not hundreds of
millions of dollars why because the more
money you make the more money you can
give back so you gotta go in big don't
let anybody fool you and tell you that
it's not important to make big money if
you're a good person and you're watching
this and you got a good heart
and you got a giving card guess what you
know what I want people like you to do I
want you to make tens of millions of
dollars because if you make tens of
millions of dollars and you truly have a
big heart you're gonna give lots of
money away by the way if you're somebody
watching this and you say I'll give
money once I start making money
no you won't if you're stingy with ten
dollars you gotta be stingy with a
hundred thousand dollars I guarantee
you'll be stingy with ten million
dollars
so just being the spirit of giving you
know it's gonna always remember one time
I was competing with another guy and he
had a nickname of being a jerk and one
guy got up and he said something very
interesting and we were competing
hardcore we were good friends but he had
this nickname that would give him I
didn't think he was a jerk but other
people thought he was a jerk and it's
one guy got up who he didn't like this
competitor and I'm sitting this the
three of us and one guy got if he's
trying to call him out and the other guy
said you know what happens when you make
money here's all money does to you even
money just makes you more of what you
are right now if you're a jerk you're a
rich jerk if you give a lot right now
you'll give even a lot more when you
make more money it just makes you more
of what you are today not much changes
you just become more of what you are
today so going back go make lots of
money to figure out ways on how you can
contribute to society the other one is
give away books simply give away books I
don't know how many thousands of books
we've give I didn't 5,000 I don't know
how many thousands of books we've given
literally five six seven eight thousand
books because I feel the same with
somebody can impact my life by giving me
a book the way I can help change
someone's life like I just talked to a
kid right now one had at a young young
cat who was quality guy and I don't know
when I spoke to him in Palm Springs and
he says the book that made the biggest
impact of my life is loss of success
right and then you know somebody else
says another book in another book in
another book and you know you have no
idea how big of an impact you can make
in your community if you give books away
you know go figure out a way on who
impacted your life out of what age give
those books away it could be the fact
that you don't like the fact that your
parents went through a divorce go buy 50
copies of the five love languages and
give it away to people around you that
mean a lot to you and you know the
husband and wife are going through
challenges give those books away to them
it could be somebody that you're seeing
that has some drug issues go buy five of
those books and give it away to somebody
that has a drug issue depression issue
whatever it is you'd be amazed how big
of an impact you can make in someone's
life by giving some books away so the
last one is surprise a family how do you
surprise the family make them
for them surprise them stop by someone's
house and you know find out what gifts
the kids want and just surprise it this
is a very good season November December
to surprise people make people feel good
believe me you will enjoy yourself more
if you go out and give back during this
season so with that being said this is
the response to many of you that sent me
messages giving back how to give back
and why you should give back so with
that being said if you got some ways
that you give back that is different
than what I said please post your
comment on the bottom and if you have
not subscribed to this channel please do
so by subscribing clicking on the
subscribe button on the bottom and this
lady doesn't sound like she's gonna stop
talking someone who lets you go with the
distraction we got and I look forward to
next week's episode from the office
where I got some exciting since I'm
going to share with everybody take
everybody bye-bye
Oh bye
you